on sait lever tous les matins comme un
matin en normal on a on a déjeuné il
était fatigué il ya eu la visite d'un
ami agriculteur qui a pas duré très
longtemps
pour moi tout allait tout allait bien en
fait il était certes fatigués mais tout
allait bien c'était un jour comme les
autres et à travailler alors à
travailler tous les trois avec eux avec
son petit frère
tout se passait bien et à l'heure du
midi
on s'est assis sur un mandat on a ri il
m'a embrassé j'ai perdu juste cinq
minutes
et là j'ai commencé à dire à son frère
que ça m'inquiéter parce que je ne
trouvais pas donc on s'est mis à le hâle
cherché à l'appeler sur son téléphone et
ça répondait pas au bout de cinq minutes
on a entendu son téléphone sonnait dans
un de nos bâtiments
et quand son frère il a monté les
marches il a crié j'ai compris que ma
vie elle avait basculé dans l'enfer où
ils avaient retrouvé pendu dans le
grenier oui il y avait il ya eu il ya eu
des signes puisqu'il avait déjà fait une
première tentative de suicide un an vaut
mais ce qui a vu d'autres signes depuis
quelques jours quelques temps ou pas du
tout papa de signes qui me montrait que
ce 27 octobre
j'allais le perdre définitivement il
était certes très fatigué après il y
avait beaucoup de charges de travail
parce qu'on n'était pas automatisé et on
faisait tout à la main il y avait des
charges administratives aussi qui
n'était pas simple du tout à gérer mais
n'ont jamais j'aurais cru que
en me levant ce jour-là à 13h on allait
le retrouvé pendu et que le samu allait
m'annoncer à 15h qu' il pouvait plus
rien faire
le 28 février 2016 il avait essayé de se
pendre à une poutre dans votre moulin
qu'est-ce qui vous disais quand il
essayait de se pendre première fois vous
avez certainement essayer de dire qu'est
ce qui se passe pourquoi quelqu es les
télés les raisons de son mal être
la première fois que j'ai les découverts
pendus le 28 février 2016
tout de suite j'ai décroché parce que on
ne peut pas laisser son mari pendu comme
ça il m'a demandé pourquoi j'avais fait
ça pourquoi j'avais décroché
donc j'ai tout simplement expliqué que
j'aidais mais que c'était pas possible
de laisser accrocher de cette manière là
mais après c'est un déni total il s'en
souvenait limite il avait occulté sa
tête il s'en souvenait pas en fait qu'il
était
qui s'était pendu depuis cinq ans mais
son médecin pas autre chose mais quand
on a été chez le médecin il s'est même
pas lui-même n'a pas dit je me suis
pendu la veille c'est moi qui ai dit au
médecin jeu il s'est pendu gelé retrouvé
pendu donc on est parti dans un dans une
dépression sévère où il a fallu être la
présente très près tout le temps au
quotidien du matin au soir même la nuit
parce que ces décès d angoisse bien sûr
que ça soit la journée ou la nuit c'est
des angoisses mais je pensais que
c'était derrière nous vraiment la
dépression de nom parce qu'on est au
fond dans guérit jamais mais vous
pensiez qu'il est que cet accueil a
jamais il l'aurait il l'aurait fait
jimmy mohamed vous lire agir oui parce
que le problème quand on va voir le
médecin malheureusement le médecin il a
pas dix mille choses à proposer c'est un
arrêt maladie mais les agriculteurs ne
peuvent pas s'arrêter parce que s'ils
s'arrêtent c'est toute la production sur
l'arête et 2 des anxiolytiques ou des
antidépresseurs dont les traitements
sont souvent incompatibles avec la
conduite d'engins donc il faudrait qu'on
fasse quelque chose alors c'est sûr
qu'il vaut toujours mieux les rémunérer
mais il faudra aussi peut-être qu'on
leur propose lorsqu on les arrête de les
payer dès le premier jours d'arrêt
maladie pour qu'il se dise ok je mets en
sécurité je vais avoir une rente qui me
permet de payer mes charges et de
subvenir aux besoins de ma famille parce
que l'agriculteur il cherche globalement
pas aller aux abois hamas
il veut juste payer ses charges et
nourrir sa famille dignement et deuxième
chose c'est s'il s'arrête qu'on puisse
le remplacer
et lorsqu'on leur en place qu'ils soient
payés dignement et peut-être que là on
aurait des agriculteurs qui vont un peu
plus se soigner et du coup
malheureusement peut-être un peu moins
se suffisait pas ce qu'il vaut être en
sécurité se dire j'ai plus de charge de
travail
je n'ai plus de problème d'argent sur le
court et moyen terme donc je pense que
ça va nous coûter de l'argent parce que
effectivement ça coûtera de l'argent je
pense pour que ce que pour ceux qui
nourrissent nos enfants on peut le faire
on peut faire cet effort supplémentaire
de supprimer le délai de carence et de
les payer à hauteur de leurs charmes et
jimmy au delà du délai de carence et de
la maladie quand ils vont bien au niveau
de la santé 450 euros par mois
oui c'est ça l'est beaucoup moins pour
les personnes autant sur les dégâts de
père sport 2 % des agriculteurs sont à
305 350 donc d'imaginer et il en parle
pas d'un agriculteur malades ou qui va
mal on prend des directeurs qui se lève
tous les matins
ibos witikon pas ses heures 350 c est
digne au 21e siècle c'est andy
à croire c'est ça c'est ça qui va passer
contre haïti lundi au dimanche pour tout
sourire et on n'est même pas payé c'est
sympa mais au fond il est là et on n'est
pas payé c'est incroyable juillet une
grosse urgence vraiment dans
l'agriculture est bâchée au niveau des
désagréments heures alors on en parle
voilà où on en vient à en parler c'est
que les problèmes auxquels vous faisiez
face c'est que dès la première année
vous avez eu des problèmes financiers
vous n'avez sortie que 260 cimpor vous
viviez avec 300 euros par mois à 2 vos
journées c'était 100% d'exploitation
dont vous n'êtes jamais parti en
vacances
jamais sans rêve c'était de partir à la
réunion mais malheureusement ça s'est
légèrement vacances voyages de ne jamais
jamais 70 heures par semaine
oui minimum vous avez aussi une invasion
de rats
oui on a une invasion de rats fin 2016
c'est ça qui a aussi mis en péril notre
exploitation parce qu'au début on voit
trois souris de rencontre dans toute
exploitation français ça veut pas dire
que c'est sale c'est juste c'est la
nature sauf que l'uriné des rats
empoisonné
notre élevage au niveau des truies donc
devenue stérile voilà on avait beau les
ainsi miné elle ne prenait pas donc je
sur dix huit fruits plein on a vécu une
truie plein et ça ça l'euro ça soit la
savane martin il ya eu des actifs sont
accumulés là bas il ya eu les dettes qui
se sont accumulés après la crise du porc
est arrivé donc on perd des 80000 euros
en allant sur un élevage de 53 imaginez
ce qu'ils avaient trois fois notre
élevage ça devait être énorme
et alors et le prix du porc qui a un
euro du kilo 1 euro du kilo donc si
c'est ça aussi c'est les gens et qu'ils
se disent ah mais non la chute de 8,8
euros 10 euros ou j'ai déjà vu des
morceaux à 19 euros du kilo amis les
riches l'éleveur pourquoi il se plaint
jeu pourquoi ils vont manifester
pourquoi ils salissent les routes ou
pourquoi ceux ci et d'autres causes mais
nous on n'a que 1 euro dans notre poche
et on nous dit débrouillez vous avec ça
chiant alors vous dites c'est le sus
c'est le système qui a tué mon mari ou
les banques les organismes sur le manque
d'accompagnement des agriculteurs on les
tue tous les jours c'est de la non
assistance à personne en danger et c'est
vrai que vous l'avez dit cette phrase on
nourrit la france entière mais personne
ne nous aide
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce que dit
camille quand elle dit c'est le système
qui a tué mon mari monsieur hans est
vrai qu'il ya une urgence à raisonnable
au niveau de l'agriculture au niveau des
agriculteurs et on a l'impression que ça
n'avance pas et que la l'urgence mais et
vous parlez justice sociale souvent dans
ce pays moi je pense que depuis mai des
années des décennies le monde agricole
et est un monde totalement oublié et
vous rappelez yééé mon avis il faut le
rappeler sans cesse c'est que
l'agriculture c'est une grande tradition
française au travers de l'histoire
l'agriculture elle est essentielle à
notre vie de tous les jours
et moi je m'associe vraiment alors
pleinement à ce que disait karim et et
jimmy c'est à dire que je ne je
connaissais le niveau de salaire moyen
je l'avais lu mais je ne peux pas
imaginer qu'en france aujourd'hui avec
le mal que vous donnez à travailler le
nombre d'heures vous travaillez vous
gagnez aussi peu je trouve que c'est
mais vraiment c'est un scandale absolu
et je pense que la puissance publique de
ray s'emparer de ce sujet c'est ça doit
être femme ans ça doit être pour moi ces
priorités priori c -b
alors il y aura oui oui oui lesquels
demandez à tenez vous bien au
supermarché d'augmenter les tarifs sur
certains produits type nutella coca et
c'est en disant bas et vous voudrez bien
s'il vous plaît les sous que vous gagnez
en plus les rebasculer sur les agrès
mais c'est faux c'est totalement fini à
la dernière de cette famille s'il vous
plaît à les y laisser parler camille oui
mais les supermarchés qui disent on
augmente au nom augmente le prix de la
viande pour se prendre moins de marge et
donner aux agriculteurs mais c'est
totalement fou on n'a jamais vu la
couleur d'un enfant qu'on n'a jamais vu
un sens eux ne l'ont essayé on parlait
de tabou tout à l'heure mais c'est
exactement ça et c'est le progrès au
problème parce qu'aujourd'hui on en
parle parce que camille a eu le courage
d'écrire son livre et a le courage
aujourd'hui d'en parler ou on en parle
oui au moment du salon de l'agriculture
on en parle pendant les campagnes
électorales
on en parle quand effectivement on
connaît qu'il ya où il ya un décès plus
visible que les autres le chiffre de 1
agriculteurs par jour ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure avec camille c'est encore
loin de la réalité parce qu'un
agriculteur qui meurent pas sur son
exploitation il n'est même pas
considérés comme suicidaires
agriculteurs et moi je suis très touché
parce que à la fois au delà de la
souffrance de camille ce soir elle
maintenant elle mène un combat pour les
autres et c'est grâce à ça qu'on va
j'espère enfin ouvrez les yeux parce que
la réalité c'est que le problème est
tellement profond à la fois des charges
des contrôles des difficultés avec la
banque qu' il faudrait carrément un plan
global avec un investissement complet et
là ya pas de luc poli des années de
droite ou de gauche pour changer la
chose parce que l'agriculteur
l'agriculture c'est le poumon de la
france je suis ici on fait rien
aujourd'hui
si on fait rien aujourd'hui c'est un
état d'urgence qu'il faut décréter pour
la grille que je pense qu'il faut le
dessus fait rien aujourd'hui chargé
district secteur dans quelques mois dans
quelques mois quelques années on aura
plus d'agriculteurs et ce ne sera plus
la france
tributaire des grands il ya dans tout
baigne à tous mais d'abord mais aussi
prendre l'oseille là
les danses est dans cet état d'urgence
raquette il faut voilà faut créer des
lois qu'ils puissent voilà aller
chercher dans les présentes sur un
chantier qui presque insurmontable non
il est lié à la menthe et ouvriers à la
boîte si je peux te si je peux
m'exprimer il est lié à la volonté
politique manger donnerait quatre
exemples très vite qu'on pourrait
prendre demain on dit les circuits
courts les circuits tenir elle veut dire
qu'il faut donner la possibilité aux
collectivités
malgré des appels d'offres donc de faire
le choix de l'agriculteur le plus proche
celui de pour nourrir les enfants dans
les cantines et autres c'est pas
aujourd'hui on te dit il faut aller par
les appels d'offres en appel d'offres
c'est le moins disant
donc on est capable aujourd'hui d'aller
chercher de la marchandise des fruits
des légumes et autres qui sont à
l'étranger ne sont pas produits par nos
agriculteurs donc ça c'est le premier
point favoriser les circuits courts
c'est bon pour l'écologie c'est bon pour
le pouvoir d'achat des agriculteurs l'a
pas récente
est ce que c'est la pac c'est la
politique agricole commune 6 décembre
snf milliards toutes ces 9 milliards
chaque année deux qui sont distribués
aux agriculteurs
vous savez on voit la pac ou 80% de la
pac va à 20 % des agriculteurs
ça veut dire qu'à 80 % des agriculteurs
qui ne touchent pas la pac
cette répartition demain on le décide
politiquement elle n'est plus la même
troisième point les normes les normes
qu'on impose à nos agriculteurs
pourquoi ne s'impose pas aux produits
qu'on fait rentrer chez nous ça veut
dire que nos agriculteurs on leur
demande d'être vertueux de gagner 350
euros par mois mais les agriculteurs
autres à l'étranger qu'il faut rentrer
les produits pesticides et de la viande
de cucq et kesha bélizaire gourmand à là
tout va bien
les autres y z'ont pas de norme donc à
un moment donné si on veut sauver nos
agriculteurs on prend quelques décisions
politiques immédiatement on les protège
et le dernier point c'est ce que disait
raquel les marges des grandes surfaces
c'est pas les pros les prix qu'il faut
qu'elles augmentent pour nous
consommateurs c'est leur marge qui doit
diminuer
à prix égal il faut que vous gagnez plus
c'est faux il faut gagner plus agathe et
à l'époque
des gilet jaune quand le combat battait
son plein on avait reçu sur ce plateau
des agriculteurs olivier notamment audi
viennent notamment qui nous parler et
qui ne témoignaient de vos conditions de
travail scandaleuses indigne il avait
des revendications claires il avait des
revendications réalisable et il parlait
notamment de la reconnaissance de votre
travail comme un travail dits pénibles
la peña by la pénibilité du travail
d'agriculteur qui vous fait travailler
sans relâche dans des conditions parfois
extrêmement dur dehors qu'il neige qu'il
pleuve qu'il vente partout vous devez
continuer à travailler pour que votre
exploitation subissent et pour que votre
famille subsistent parce que quand en
france on donne à vous et votre mari 300
euros par mois on leur dit en gros vous
ne comptez pas on ne vous considère pas
vous n'avez pas d'importance votre
travail n'a pas d'importance
et ce sentiment de rejet et d'exclusion
provoque effectivement ce mal-être chez
nombre d'entre vous mais c'est
intolérable qu'on ne fasse pas des
choses contre ça eric naulleau est aussi
sans doute une responsabilité médiatique
parce que les paysans sont des gens qui
meurent loin des villes sont à des
médias loin des regards il ya une série
de raymond depardon sur les paysans
c'est parfois une solitude
extraordinaire presque impossible à
concevoir
il faut qu'ils aient plus d'émissions
comme la nôtre qui met ça sur le tapis
ce ne soit pas une fois de temps en
temps chaque fois qu'un drame mais voilà
on aime resto vraiment il faut vraiment
politique économique est acquise en moi
j'ai dit non il n'est pas né l'a reçu en
réalité ça devient banal c'est que je
suis serriculteurs et banalisé d'ariel
et très très gros sur le droit camus
j'aimerais me tourner vers vous quel
message vous avez envie de faire passer
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous avez
envie de dire parce que vous maintenant
vous avez quitté l'exploitation c'est
votre beau frère qui a repris
l'exploitation il a arrêté
l'exploitation il a abandonné l'élevage
des porcs vous aujourd'hui
vous occupez d'enfants qu'est ce que
vous avez envie de dire à tous les
agriculteurs et qu'est ce que vous avez
dit envie de dire au gouvernement après
le drame qui vous est arrivé alors sur
l'exploitation les deux d'accord je
m'installe l'année prochaine d'accord si
vous continuez malgré ça parce que c'est
une question que l'on se pose elle
continua basket handi rarement est ce
qui pousse les agriculteurs hormis la
passion parce qu'aucun tu penses qu'on
prend n'importe quelle profession 400
moi on arrête tous se reconvertit on
fait autre chose qu'est ce qui vous
pousse malgré tout ce qui s'est passé et
les conditions de coacher de travail et
1 c'est facile de dire on arrête tous à
400 euros par mo quand ça vient de son
grand-père de son père c'est juste
impossible arrêté il ya un héritage y en
a c'est trois générations et vous rendez
compte le poids de se dire mon grand
père il a réussi mon père certes il est
décédé à 46 ans mais larry là il
réussissait et moi et moi je n'arrive
pas moi j'arrive pas malgré que je
nourris la france entière on n'arrive
pas à vivre de son métier gens qui a un
poids il ya un poids moi je continue
parce que c'est son héritage c'est mon
héritage
j'ai mon beau-frère aussi avec moi vous
rendez compte si la plus on perd il a pu
son frère aujourd'hui s'il n'a pas
s'accompagner s'il ne m'a pas au fond il
acquit cesser son héritage aussi
moi aujourd'hui je me suis battue en
justice pour continuer l'exploitation
donc oui je suis plus l'élevage des
porcs mais je continue d'exploiter les
terres et parce qu'il faut pas lâcher et
c'est ça aussi l'huile il a lâché parce
qu'il était trop fatigué il me disait
j'ai mal dans ma tête mais mais par
contre moi je suis encore forte
ce que j'ai envie de dire aujourd'hui
c'est que moi on peut plus m'aider il
est trop tard d'accord moi voilà j'ai
enterré mon mari j'ai 24 ans j'étais à
deux mois de mai 25 engins 27 ans au
mois de décembre
ça va faire deux ans il est trop tard
mais il n'est pas trop tard pour les
autres faut qu'on arrête ça faut
vraiment qu'on arrête ça
[Applaudissements]
ainsi qu'annick anigo
le mal est fait
très beau témoignage du mercy kamiz
avoir été avec nous ce soir